>> UNFORTUNATELY FOR NEW
YORKERS, THIS WASN'T THE ONLY
STORY YESTERDAY.
YOU'RE READING ABOUT SOMEBODY
ELSE THAT GOT STABBED ON A NEW
YORK CITY SUBWAY.
SOMEBODY ELSE WHO GOT SLASHED IN
THE EAST VILLAGE.
I MEAN, THIS IS DAY AFTER DAY
AFTER DAY AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
PARENTS AND A LOT OF FAMILIES
DEALING WITH THIS REALITY OF
RISING CRIME IN NEW YORK FOR US,
FORTUNATELY, OUR DAUGHTERS KNEW
EXACTLY HOW TO RESPOND.
LISTEN, THEY WERE SITTING THERE
AT THE KITCHEN TABLE DOING
HOMEWORK AND BULLETS STARTED
GOING OFF ALL AROUND THEM AND WE
DON'T LIVE IN, YOU KNOW, SOME
HUGE HOUSE WITH, YOU KNOW, THIS
ISN'T A GATED COMMUNITY.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
REALLY JUST FEET FROM WHERE THEY
WERE SITTING.
>> Carley: CONGRESSMAN AND NEW
YORK GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE LEE
ZELDIN CALLS OUT VIOLENT CRIME
IN NEW YORK.
>> Brian: DANGER OUTSIDE HIS
HOME WHERE HIS TWO DAUGHTERS
WERE DOING HOMEWORK.
>> Steve: SEAN HANNITY JOINS US
WITH LIVE REACTION ON THIS
COLUMBUS DAY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU OOCHLT HOW
ARE YOU DOING?
>> Steve: WE'RE DOING OK.
THE COPS SAID THIS IS TARGETED
AND APPARENTLY A GANG THING.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL THAT
MUCH BETTER.
CHICAGO NUMBERS, GANG RELATED.
THOSE CRIME STATS LOOK LIKE ZIP
CODES.
>> YOU HAVE ALL THE CRIMES
HAPPENING.
IT'S INTERESTING TO WATCH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, JOE BIDEN SAID
WE'LL GIVE MORE MONEY TO THE
POLICE.
BUT WHETHER HE LIKES IT OR NOT,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS THE
PARTY OF DEFUND, DISMANTLE AND
THESE CRAZY, INSANE NO BAIL
LAWS.
STEVE, SINCE 2009 ON THIS
NETWORK, ON MY TV SHOW, I'VE
BEEN SCROLLING THE NAMES THAT
PEOPLE NEVER READ ABOUT, NEVER
HEAR ABOUT, PEOPLE SHOT AND SHOT
AND KILLED IN CHICAGO.
YOU GOT CRIME.
IT IS SO BAD.
IT IS SO OUT OF CONTROL.
BASICALLY, COPS WHO ARE AFRAID
TO DO THEIR JOB.
THEY CUT A BILLION DOLLARS OUT
OF THE NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT BUDGET.
NOW, THIS HAPPENS IN FRONT OF
LEE ZELDIN'S HOME.
I MEAN, WHERE HE LIVES IN LONG
ISLAND IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHERE
BRIAN LIVES IN LONG ISLAND.
IT'S HAPPENING EVERYWHERE.
MY FAVORITE IS YOU HAVE ONE BANK
ROBBER GETS CAUGHT ROBBING A
BANK, NO BAIL LAW.
GETS OUT, AND ROBS ANOTHER BANK.
GETS OUT AGAIN AND ROBS ANOTHER
BANK.
I THINK AROUND FIVE BANKS IN
TOTAL.
IT'S REALLY THE VIOLENT CRIME
THAT IS TOP OF MIND FOR MOST
VOTERS.
WE GOT AN ELECTION IN 29 DAYS.
INFLATION IS AT A 41-YEAR HIGH.
WE HAVE RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES.
WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
YOU CANNOT PURSUE HAPPINESS IN
THIS COUNTRY IF YOU DON'T HAVE
LAW AND ORDER AND SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
THIS IS EVERY SMALL TOWN, EVERY
BIG CITY, ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND I WOULD ARGUE ALL OF THESE
WIDE OPEN BORDERS, IT'S ALL
GOING TO PLAY A PART.
WHETHER THIS TURNS INTO THE WAVE
ELECTION SOME ARE PREDICTING.
I'M NOT WILLING TO GO THERE.
WE'LL SEE.
BUT IF REPUBLICANS HAVE A WAVE
ELECTION WIN, LAW AND ORDER IS
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE A BIG
PART OF IT.
>> Carley: CERTAINLY IS.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS CRIME ISSUE, I WAS AT A
DRUGSTORE IN NEW YORK CITY AND
SOMEBODY WALKED IN.
THEY STOLE ALL THE BABY FORMULA,
ALL THE DIAPERS AND THEN THEY
WALKED OUT OF THE STORE.
AND THEN I HEARD ONE OF THE
EMPLOYEES SAY, YOU KNOW, THE GUY
DIDN'T EVEN RUN OUT OF THE
STORE.
HE WAITED FOR THE BUS WITH HIS
BAG OF STOLEN STUFF.
>> HE DIDN'T RUN AWAY.
HE STAYED THERE.
>> Carley: THAT'S HOW EMBOLDENED
CRIMINALS ARE RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
A HUGE TOPIC OF CONVERSATION, AS
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY IN NEW YORK
FEELS LESS SAFE BECAUSE CRIME IS
ON RANDOM.
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE IS FORMER
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK DAVID
PATTERSON, DEMOCRAT, LISTEN TO
WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
>> FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE EVEN IN
THE LATE 1980s AND 1990s WHEN
THE CRIME RATE WAS KILLING 2,000
PEOPLE A YEAR, I NEVER FELT AS
UNSAFE AS I DO NOW JUST WALKING
AROUND AND GOD FORBID SOMETIMES
WE TAKE THE SUBWAY HOME FROM
WABC, AND YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT
AN ASSAULT ON THE SUBWAY ALMOST
EVERY OTHER DAY.
>> Carley: YEAH.
CRIME DOESN'T CARE ABOUT YOUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
>> LOOK, GOVERNOR PATTERSON IS A
DEMOCRAT, AND PRETTY LEFT WING
AND HE'S RECOGNIZING THE
OBVIOUS.
WHAT'S AMAZING THIS YEAR THAT I
DON'T THINK WE'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY THAT ARE DEMOCRATS,
YOU KNOW, THEY THOUGHT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT THE DOBBS DECISION
WOULD GIVE THEM A LEG UP IN
TERMS OF GETTING THEIR BASE
MOTIVATED.
BUT THEN THEY START TAKING THIS
RADICAL EXTREME POSITION THAT
ABORTION SHOULD BE ALLOWED UP
UNTIL THE MOMENT OF BIRTH.
I DON'T KNOW ANY DEMOCRAT OR
ANYBODY THAT I KNOW THAT SAYS
THEY'RE PRO CHOICE THAT TAKES
THAT RADICAL POSITION.
BUT YOU HAVE PEOPLE -- THE
GUBERNATORIAL DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE IN ARIZONA TOOK THE
POSITION YESTERDAY.
STACEY ABRAMS HAS NO IDEA ABOUT
SCIENCE, WHEN THE HEARTBEAT
BEGINS.
WOULDN'T GIVE A DEFINITION.
GUYS LIKE JOHN FEDDERMAN IN THE
SENATE, RUNNING FOR SENATE,
BARNES, WARNOCK, NO RESTRICTIONS
AT ALL WHATSOEVER ON ABORTION.
THAT WILL BE ON THE BALLOT, I
KNOW, AS WELL.
BUT PATTERSON WAS RIGHT, I MEAN,
WE HAVE MORE EXAMPLES THAN WE'VE
EVER HAD BEFORE OF COMMUTERS IN
NEW YORK.
THEY GO ON THE SUBWAY SYSTEM,
AND THEY'RE BEING THROWN RIGHT
IN FRONT OF TRAINS AND SOME OF
THEM SADLY ARE DYING.
AND PEOPLE SEE IT.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF YOU DON'T FEEL
SAFE AND SECURE, YOU CANNOT LIVE
YOUR LIFE, PERIOD, END OF
SENTENCE.
THAT BECOMES A QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUE.
WHEN YOU HAVE RECORD HIGH
INFLATION AND ADD THAT TO RECORD
HIGH GAS PRICES AND THE AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD IS PAYING AN EXTRA, ON
AVERAGE, ACCORDING TO THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION, $7200 A
YEAR FOR THE VERY SAME ITEMS
THEY PURCHASED WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT, THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE AN IMPACT AT THE POLLS.
WHETHER IT'S PICKED UP BY
POLLSTERS OR NOT.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
NEWSDAY, HOMETOWN PAPER IN LONG
ISLAND, FRONT PAGE, BOOSTERS.
HE'S ON PAGE 10.
"NEW YORK POST," FRONT PAGE, BIG
STORY.
HE ALSO THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROMOTED JOSHA NORKIN, THE
GENIUS BEHIND THE ZERO CASH
BAIL.
HE JUST GOT A PROMOTION TO
DEPUTY COUNSEL SO SHE DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT CRIME.
NO INTEREST IN DEBATING.
SHE FEELS SHE'S GOING TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK.
THAT'S A BAD SIGN.
>> BRIAN, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
HAPPENING ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
IS ALMOST EVERY DEMOCRATIC
GUBERNATORIAL, SENATORIAL
CANDIDATE HAS TAKEN ON THE SAME
STRATEGY KIND OF LIKE BIDEN IN
2020.
HIDE IN THE BUNKER.
HIDE FROM THE PRESS.
DON'T AGREE TO DEBATES.
DON'T ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE MEDIA IS COMPLIANT IF THEY
ASK YOU A QUESTION, IT'S GOING
TO BE A SOFTBALL ANYWAY.
AND HOPE YOU CAN RUN OUT THE
CLOCK.
AND IF YOU DO AGREE TO DEBATE,
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT LIKE, FOR
EXAMPLE, JOHN FEDDERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA THE WEEK BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
AND HE WANTS A TELEPROMPTER WITH
CLOSED CAPTIONING.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S STRATEGY IS
SHE WANTS TO GO ON A STATE
LISTENING TOUR.
GOVERNOR, YOU DON'T NEED TO
LISTEN.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS OPEN UP A
NEWSPAPER LIKE BRIAN SAID AND
MAYBE NOT NEWSDAY OR "THE DAILY
NEWS" OR "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
OPEN UP "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" OR "THE NEW YORK POST"
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE ARE NOT SAFE AND SECURE.
LOOK, WE'RE SETTING RECORD AFTER
RECORD IN TERMS OF MURDERS,
VIOLENT CRIME, CARJACKINGS IN
ALMOST EVERY BIG CITY IN THE
COUNTRY.
THE RED STATES THAT DO SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I KNOW THAT
GOVERNOR DESANTIS GOT HIT ON
THIS.
HE'S SAYING REMEMBER, WE'RE A
SECOND AMENDMENT STATE.
PEOPLE IN FLORIDA HAVE THE RIGHT
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
I INTERVIEWED, I'VE SEEN THE
VIDEO YOU'RE RUNNING RIGHT NOW.
I INTERVIEWED THIS WOMAN.
SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO LOSE AT
LEAST ONE EYE AND MAY LOSE SIGHT
IN BOTH EYES AS A RESULT OF THAT
RANDOM BEATING IN A SUBWAY IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THIS HAS GOT TO STOP.
GOVERNMENT'S NUMBER ONE ROLE IS
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
IT HAS TO BE ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER.
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S LAW AND
ORDER AT THE BORDER.
WE CAN'T AID AND ABET LAW
BREAKING.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT INVOLVED IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, SAYING WE'RE
NOT A SANCTUARY STATE, WE'LL
SEASONED THEM TO NEW Y